apparently Democrats don't have that
value they don't have that ship in their
head that goes you know what I don't
want to personally be embarrassed by
this I'm going to speak out against it
they all go along with it they're
willing to be just totally humiliated as
long as it's for a greater cause in
their in their brain and this is the
greatest cause for them they've been
wanting to indict him for years I don't
think they are humiliated though I don't
think they care I think that they this
is activism journalists I mean it's not
journalism but this is state-run yeah
they may be incapable I mean at some
point like when do we admit that these
mainstream you know propaganda pieces
are I mean who are they effectively
working for I mean they're able to run
stuff every single day completely not
factual they don't do retractions but
damage is already done
they sometimes do attractions because
they make money on that too so you can
write you can write a news story Ian
Crossland does backflip and then
everyone's shocked and they click it I
think it's a million views and it's fake
news then the next day you run another
story apologies Ian actually did a front
flip and then you try and milk the views